Caryn's with us in california hi Karen
and welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
how are you do better than I deserve
what's up
thanks I am a single mom I am fully
responsible for my child financially
time everything and I have about $80,000
left in my debt snowball my car is
16,000 of that it I checked on Kelley
Blue Book and it's worth about thirteen
five to fourteen five and I'm just
wondering if I should if I should sell
it if it's going to blow up the log jam
what's your household income I think
this year it will be about sixty
thousand what city do you live in in
California I am smack dab in the middle
of LA hmm I am in a rent controlled
apartment though so I am lucky that my
rent is only about $800 a month what you
do for a living I'm a teacher and a
tutor so all in all this is Joe - so
she's not in school yeah I have some
angels right now who are taking care of
her for free Wow so I my childcare costs
in a month are usually around four to
five hundred dollars which in LA is
that's unheard of a fraction don't know
and so yeah you do have angels and you
have a great rent you do have a lot of
debt yeah you make enough this car is
not killing me in and of itself and you
ask yourself my self the question does
the car set me free and it really
doesn't other than the payment might be
outlandish you have a ridiculous
interest rate on this no the payment is
320 that's not too bad it's bad I don't
like it but I mean it's not like you
told me I got a twenty two percent
interest rate I'm paying five hundred
bucks on this stupid fifteen thousand
our car which that might force you to
sell it you know but I I think you I
think you look at your budget you you've
been
living on the cheap trying to survive
because you're the sole breadwinner so
responsible you have to spare your
shoulders and get her done and you're a
brave warrior and I appreciate you I
think if you do the academic
intellectual exercise of the budget in
detail you're probably going to find
money not because you've been
misbehaving and you're some kind of
princess but because I think there's
always some juice to squeeze yeah yeah I
got every dollar there you go I'm still
getting used to it there you go
yeah you're just early in this process
to sell the car now if you call me back
and you say man I've been fighting this
bear with a switch for two years I can't
I can't seem to get anywhere I got to
sell this thing to get out okay that's
fine that's fine give her give her a
shot then but you're new enough to some
of the things we're telling you to do to
get efficiencies that I'm gonna delay
the car sale cuz it's gonna bring a lot
of pain to you when you sell it yeah so
well and then the other question I would
ask you the other question I was asking
where are you going to be in 15 years
I hope not in LA anymore okay so let's
start making plans yeah maybe sooner
rather than later I'm not saying if this
year but I want to aim at something
besides Friday and survival yeah
and you know that's your first step is
survival we do that and you've done a
great job with that warrior well done
okay but long-term what does the mother
of a 17 year old what does her career
look like 15 years from today and where
are we raising this teenager and what is
our income then and our outgo and we're
prospering and we've set up a great
college fund and you're looking at a
wonderful retirement ahead of you and
what are steps we've got to do in the
next five years to be that person 15
years from today
that'll sometimes jog you loose on the
log jam too so think it through take it
through you've done a good job surviving
mom you did a good job I'm proud of you
so let's take it up from survival into
prosperity
hold on and I'll have Kelly pick up
we're gonna put you into Financial Peace
University which will give you every
dollar plus and the whole teaching all
around here we're gonna walk with you
and help you I'm proud of you